[Musik]
konsequent und unbarmherzig trapping den
umbau chinas zu einem absolutistischen
totalitären system vorwand um seinen
untertanen in nationalistischen zombies
zu verwandeln die parteiinternen
widersacher um seine liberalen sind
endgültig auszuschalten wo sich selbst
zum de facto diktator auf lebenszeit
küren zu lassen das motto lautet in
china für china das regime nimmt den
wirtschaftlichen profit aus den
welthandel zwar gerne mit setzt jedoch
immer mehr auf die vor allem sozial und
kulturell entkoppelung vom ausland waren
2021 immerhin noch 0,06 prozent der
chinesischen bevölkerung ausländer hat
sich diese ohnehin schon sehr niedrige
zahl die nur einem jahr mehr als
halbiert und im sommer wird ein
regelrechter exodus erwartet kaum noch
ein experte dürfte in china bleiben
dabei ist es nicht nur die brutale zero
cockpit politik welche die meisten von
ihnen dazu bringt das land zu verlassen
die chinesische gesellschaft wird
insgesamt intoleranter gegenüber
ausländern die einstellung der menschen
durch die propaganda immer
nationalistischer mancherorts ist die
stimmung geradezu aufgepeitscht und
voller hass es wird das narrativ
gesprochen der westen sei für corona
verantwortlich es ist also klar die von
denk shopping einst initiierte öffnung
des reiches der mitte wird nun
rückabgewickelt zumindest in allen
bereichen die nicht die wirtschaft
betreffen denn sie sieht in der
weltoffenheit eine bedrohung seines
absoluten machtanspruch
[Musik]
zu groß ist die gefahr für ihn die
totale überwachung und kontrolle der
einwohner konnte durch ausländische
elemente gestört werden einen ganz
besonderer dorn im auge sind ihm dabei
jene international vernetzten großstädte
mit einer diversen pluralistisch
kreative und weltoffene szene wie
shanghai oder shenzhen im great barrier
über welches dir schon ein eigenes video
gedreht haben das darin beschriebene
ambivalente verhältnis schießt zu diesen
hightech boom regionen und ihren eliten
ist mittlerweile jedoch in ihre gezielte
und offenen bekämpfung übergegangen zu
welcher unter anderem auch die
unmenschlichen lockt aus der zero
corvette politik dienen die global
orientierte bevölkerung dieser
metropolen soll mürbe gemacht
gleichgeschaltet und wieder auf
nationalistischen kurs gebracht werden
natürlich handelt es sich für sie um
eine hochgradig riskante strategie denn
diese wirtschaftsregionen die er sich
gefügig machen will sind der motor der
welt macht chinas ohne ihre
leistungsfähigkeit hält das land wieder
auf das niveau einer agrargesellschaft
zurück weil es jedoch wird nicht mal
über die rohstoffe und lebensmittel
produktion verfügt um die eigene
bevölkerung zur versorgung von den
finanzmitteln für die alimentierung des
kommenden winters tsunamis mal ganz zu
schweigen schießt plan hat daher noch
eine weitere von der weltöffentlichkeit
weitgehend übersehene komponente sein
gedanke während ich die existierenden
widerspenstigen metropolen aus hunger
schaffe ich mir einfach meine eigenen
neuen mega städte solche in dem ich die
macht von vornherein mit niemandem
teilen werde weder mit unternehmen noch
mit regionalfürsten höchstens vielleicht
mit einer künstlichen intelligenz
schiebel der chinesischen sonnenkönig
des 21 jahrhunderts werden und so manche
von euch wird sagen gut china war schon
in der vergangenheit ein experte darin
ganze städte von grund auf aus dem boden
zu stampfen städte die in vielen fällen
tatsächlich danach leer stehen oder
deren belegungsraten weit unter der
ursprünglichen planung liegen aber
dieses thema wollte hier nicht weiter
vertiefen stattdessen wollen in diesem
video über ein ganz spezielles
städtebauliches mega projekt sprechen
eines dessen wirtschaftlich und falls
politische und soziale dimensionen euch
den atem verschlagen werden es geht um
nichts anderes als die wild wings
persönliches muss dieses szenario im
reallife von dem er sich erhofft das ist
ein strahlendes beispiel eine blaupause
für die gesamte künftige städteplanung
in china werden könnte und haltet euch
fest denn wenn sein plan aufgeht hat ein
weiteres großes puzzleteil zum aufbau
seines große licht des tropischen chinas
in der hand spielt hier also quasi den
simcity bürgermeister und ein
größenwahnsinnig kontroll wichtiges
muster zugleich gut wir alle haben schon
mal virtuell ein paar allmachtsfantasien
ausgelebt das problem ist nur dass es
sich diesmal nicht um sims aus bits und
bytes handle sondern um menschen aus
fleisch und blut und was man auch nicht
vergessen dass das echte leben ist kein
endlosspiel weiß man scheitert heißt es
game over und zwar für immer und je
höher man pokert desto größer können wir
den absturz sein wenn diesmal soll bei
alldem anders als bei den bisherigen
sonderwirtschaftszonen wie zum beispiel
erkennen oder dem die bombe zeigt in
shanghai
diesmal der start sprich die regierung
selbst die führende rolle bei der
entwicklung des gebietes in der lokalen
infrastruktur spielen die das
wirtschaftliche und soziale gefüge
bilden und zwar ganz bewusst im
gegensatz zu dem was die alten
metropolen groß und mächtig gemacht hat
[Musik]
wir sprechen heute über den neuen
stadtbezirk von bau den schülern ein
projekt das bereits in vollem gange ist
und das darauf abzielt zu der mega-city
des einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts zu
werden eine neue stadt die drei
ländliche bezirke in der provinz hebei
einnehmen wird kommt es an und dann
stehen aber das ist erst der anfang
obwohl das projekt davon ausgeht dass
die stadt in der ersten phase eine
fläche von 100 quadratkilometern
einnehmen wird so sie mittelfristig
sogar mehr als 2000 quadratkilometer
groß werden das ist was dreimal so groß
wie die gesamte fläche von new york city
und die wahl des standortes ist dabei
kein zufall
[Musik]
sondern liegt nämlich sowohl in der nähe
von peking als auch nahe genug an
tianjin einer wichtigen hafen und
industriestadt bis 2035 soll schon an
die technologisch fortschrittlichste am
besten vernetzte und ökologisch
nachhaltigste stadt in china werden
außerdem wäre sie nur 20 minuten vom
flughafen beijing erreichbar und dank
einer hochgeschwindigkeits zugverbindung
ebenfalls eine halbe stunde vom
stadtzentrum pekings entfernt
[Musik]
mit einem masterplan der mehrere
entwicklungsphasen bis zum jahr 2050
vorsieht sind investitionen welche die
chinesische regierung in diesen neuen
städtischen raum des spektrums städten
wird astronomisch hoch nach schätzungen
von morgan stanley geht es um ein budget
von 170 bis 300 milliarden dollar von
denen etwa die hälfte für die
ausstattung der neuen metropole mit
einer hochmodernen infrastruktur
verwendet werden soll angesichts dieser
strategischen ambitionen und der enormen
herausforderungen die damit verbunden
sind haben viele analysten und experten
dieses projekt mit dem von präsident
sheikh shopping in den 80er jahren
gefördert geschenken und dem von chancen
in den 90er jahren gefordert und bezirk
pudong in shanghai verglichen
tatsächlich war es gerade die errichtung
dieser beiden sonderwirtschaftszonen die
den grundstein für das moderne china
gelegt hat china das offen für den markt
und die welt ist aber freunde hieß
lieblingsprojekt hat nichts mit denen
seiner vorgänger gemein was sie schon
wegen ihr versucht ist nicht genau das
gegenteil zu zeigen dass ein neues mehr
zentral wirtschaftlichen elementen
gespicktes china möglich ist fest
geführt von der sogenannten
kommunistischen partei chinas es geht um
eine stadt in der nicht die
marktorientierung in die private
freiheit und initiative das wichtigste
sind seine macht des staates selbst aber
kann ein projekt bei denen die kraft und
dynamik privater initiative nicht im
vordergrund steht erfolgreich sein was
kann man aus den erfahrungen der
vergangenheit lernen wird schongang ein
erfolg oder ein misserfolg
um diese fragen fundiert beantworten zu
können werden wir erst einmal einen
genaueren blick auf engine den ersten
lichtstrahl der einstigen morgen
genommen ist asiatischen riesen das
erste erfolgreiche groß angelegte
experiment welches das chinesische
modell für immer verändert hat
[Musik]
das symbol der revolution denkt ps
liebe visuell belegt zuschauer wenn wir
über den phänomenalen wandel china
sprechen sind wir uns in den meisten
stellen weder der schwindelerregenden
geschwindigkeit muss mit der stadt fand
noch des genauen ausgangspunkt dieser
ganzen entwicklung
es begann in den späten siebziger jahren
als der damalige chinesische staatschef
deng xiaoping gewarnt wurde dass die
nahrungsmittel um die
industrieproduktion rapide sinken würden
es bestand die akute gefahr dass er eine
ähnliche szenario wie die großen
chinesischen hungers wurde wiederholen
würde weil der zwischen 1959 und 61
millionen von menschen starben aus
diesem grund beschloss bank shopping ein
führende politiker herbert as roma
reformistischen flügel der regierung
gehört hatte sein glück mit einem neuen
wirtschaftssystem zu versuchen das in
einem kleinen und armen fischerdorf mit
kommt 30.000 einwohnern begann er direkt
nähe der damals noch unter britischer
verwaltung stehen und handelsmetropole
hongkong
die rede ist natürlich von charlie sheen
[Musik]
dort in der provinz guandong berichtet
die chinesische regierung die ersten
sonderwirtschaftszonen ihrer geschichte
ein und damit den ersten raum auf dem
chinesischen festland seien momentan ära
die in dem private investitionen und
geschäfte erlaubt waren aus heutiger
sicht können wir sagen dass diese
sonderwirtschaftszone ein wichtiger
grundpfeiler für die entwicklung in
richtung des modernen chinas war jenes
chinas wie wir es heute kennen bzw wie
wir es vor der korona krise konnten um
euch mal eine vorstellung davon zu geben
das kleine fischerdorf von gerade mal
drei quadratkilometern wuchs und wuchs
zu einer riesen metropole mit sage und
schreibe 17 millionen einwohnern rund
2.000 quadratkilometern fläche und einem
bip aus dem ganz israels oder einem
viertel spaniens entspricht mit einem
durchschnittlichen jährlichen wachstum
von mehr als 20 prozent und einem pro
kopf bip von mehr als 30.000 us dollar
ist chen jian wirtschaftlich gesehen
bereits auf dem niveau einige der am
weitesten entwickelten länder der welt
es wuchs ist so stark dass sich der
wohlstand von jen in den vier
jahrzehnten seit der gründung des
wirtschaftszone haltet euch jetzt fest
und das 10.000 fache erhöht hat ja ihr
habt richtig gehört und das
zehntausendfache und das in 40 jahren
es ist daher nicht überraschend dass
genau dies der motor des neuen chinas
war dass wir heute kennen und der ort an
dem so bekannte unternehmen wie huawei
tencent dj oder sieht die hier
entstanden sind oder das ist
interessanterweise der erste ort war den
shipping besuchte nachdem er 2002 sein
amt als generalsekretär der partei
antrat jean ping begibt sich auf seine
erste inspektionsreise nach tschechien
oder erinnert dabei an den shopping die
wahl des standorts für eine der ersten
kapitalistischen sonderzonen in china
direkt neben hongkong und macao war
dabei kein zufall
[Musik]
denn damals im jahre 1979 waren hongkong
macau 24 wohlhabenderen höher
entwickelte gebiete als der rest des
chinesischen festlandes die unterschiede
zwischen den menschen und den
benachbarten concha bahn extrem genau
aus diesem grund war die wahl der
kleinstädtischen challenge an 1000
tischen der provinz guangdong der stadt
in der provinz funktion und der
inselprovinz hainan das kapitalistische
experiment der chinesischen regierung
kein zufall der in einer der schlüssel
dabei war wie schon angedeutet die
symbiose mit hongkong und macau um das
know how die aktivität und das enorme
human und finanzkapital dieser beiden
enklaven zu nutzen um die entwicklung
des chinesischen festlandes zu fördern
gleichzeitig wurde das experiment wenn
es funktioniert ein gebiet schaffen dass
die zukünftige eingliederung mag aus und
kommt ins reich der kpc erleichtert
würde und wie wir heute alle wissen ist
ihr plan sowohl wirtschaftlich als auch
politisch ein wunderbar aufgegangen
tatsache ist dass der challenger
entwicklungsmodell in den 80er und 90er
jahren als blaupause in ganz china
nachgeahmt wurde und das bis heute und
deswegen ist es eben für china als
mächtigster chinesischer präsident seit
mozart um geld so richtig sein eigenes
gegenmodell einer sonderwirtschaftszone
zu erfolg zu führen und dann dem ganzen
land aufzukaufen ein modell das wenig
mit dem ewigen zu tun hat dass china
erfolg und entwicklung brachte sondern
eher an die sowjetunion erinnert also
wollt ihr dass china der zukunft
kennenlernen zumindest wie sie sich
vorstellt dann lasst uns einen blick auf
charmant den neuen chinesischen traum
werfen
[Musik]
schieß modell für chinas zukunft
wie ihr euch bereits gesagt habe zielt
die jungs an area darauf ab mit dem
modell der traditionellen
sonderwirtschaftszone zu brechen die das
heutige china beherrscht shipping selbst
bei dieser wette obszönes summen auf ein
neues modell das seiner meinung nach die
nächsten 1000 jahre der sozialismus
chinesischer prägung anleiten wird die
1000-jährige reiche begründet von einem
großen führer der alle macht in seiner
hand hält so manches volk hat damit
schon eher um gute erfahrungen gemacht
aber mal sehen wie sie das diesmal
anstellen will vielleicht ist er ein
genie oder sowas sie ist überzeugt von
der notwendigkeit einer sehr großen
direkten rolle des staates in der
wirtschaft als dennis jeweils sehr
interessant obwohl er sich bei stern an
propagandistisch gesehen ebenfalls um
eine sonderwirtschaftszone handeln soll
ist es in wahrheit aber so dass ihr
weder machtmechanismen noch die freiheit
der marktakteure eine rolle spielen
sollen nein nichts dergleichen es ist
eine sonderzone die vollständig von der
zentralregierung gesteuert und
finanziert wird eine stadt vom und für
den start okay und woher soll dann die
ganze wirtschaftlich energie und die
leistungsanreize kommen
[Musik]
nun wir dieser grafik sehen könnt will
die chinesische regierung schon zum
größten öffentlichen investitionsprojekt
in der geschichte chinas machen und das
soll schon was heißen aber das ist noch
nicht alles
[Musik]
dieses projekt wird eben wie schon
erwähnt nicht von privaten unternehmen
geleitet sondern der staat selbst
beabsichtigt den ganzen prozess durch
eine riesige investition öffentliche
mittel zu steuern eine berücksichtigung
internationaler investition ist
überhaupt nicht mehr vorgesehen nicht
einmal die immobilienwirtschaft wird der
privaten überlassen jede einzelne
wohnkomplex der eh schon gebaut wird
wird vom staat gefördert und das
eigentum verbleibt auch bei ihm
angeblich sind ein modell ähnlich dem
singapur es umgesetzt werden über dass
wir mal ein video gedreht haben dass ich
euch verlinkt werden ob dies aber in
china auch so fair sozial und frei von
korruption vonstatten geht wie im
demokratischen stadtstaat ist stark zu
bezweifeln und übrigens china sowieso
kein richtiges privateigentum an land
gibt dann die bauern die derzeit in der
region leben und arbeiten sofort
enteignet oder halten eine entschädigung
die der staat willkürlich festgelegt
wie diese tausende von landwirten damit
umgehen und ob sie nicht den ersten
schwierigkeiten geraten interessiert
dabei eher kein na ja nicht gerade der
ideale startschuss in eine nachhaltige
zukunft aber kommen wir wieder zu den
leistungsanreizen denn ohne diese läuft
die wirtschaft nicht rund und ohne
wirtschaftliche dynamik entsteht keine
wettbewerbsfähigkeit und ohne diese gibt
es keine profite und keine ökonomische
macht also wie die skis plan hilfe aus
nun er will dass das ganze leben in
schulen der gesamte alltag eng mit der
arbeit verbunden sein wird zentrales
element dieser strategie ist ist dass
sämtlicher wohnraum zwar vom staat
gestellt wird aber fest an den
arbeitgeber gebunden ist mit dem verlust
des arbeitsplatzes verliert man auch das
recht in der stadt zu wohnen und wenn
man außen aussieht verliert man
natürlich sein recht an der wohnung der
arbeitgeber beziehungsweise die
parteikader in den führungsetagen haben
somit die volle kontrolle über das leben
und aufenthaltsrecht jedes einwohners
erinnert euch das nicht auch irgendwie
anders kavala systemen durch das in
arabische staaten gastarbeiter
ausgebeutet werden in china richten es
sich eben nicht gegen ausländer sondern
gegen chinesische binnen migranten
selbst nun ja vielleicht funktioniert
das ganze eher die witzenhäuser dubais
und katar sind ja auch dank dieses
systems entstanden kaltblütiger zynismus
regiert nun mal die welt
[Musik]
aber die grosse frage bleibt wenn dieser
große plan entworfen wurde ohne private
initiative mit einzubeziehen womit will
man ihn dann eigentlich finanzieren wie
soll eine optimale allokation von
ressourcen arbeitskräften und
finanzmitteln zu stande kommen was
erhofft sich shipping als treibende und
regelte kraft für die größte stadt
chinas die vielleicht sogar die
zukünftige hauptstadt des ganzen landes
werden könnte nun auch wenn es euch
vielleicht seltsam vorkommen sollte das
größte risiko besteht eigentlich in der
grundidee dass schon in der ersten phase
alle nicht essentiellen staatlichen
einrichtungen pekings übernehmen soll im
zuge dieses plans will die chinesische
regierung universitäten
staatsunternehmen könnten häuser
forschungszentren und organisationen
aller art dorthin verlegen alles was
sich in staatlichen besitz befindet oder
eng vom staat kontrolliert wird es ist
zwar vorgesehen ist eine gewisse private
beteiligung stattfinden kann aber nur
über konsortien die private unternehmen
zu lassen bei denen aber immer die
chinesische regierung die führung
innerhalb mit anderen worten was
shipping vorsteht ist nichts geringeres
als die schaffung einer festung einer
neuen stadt die nicht auf handeln
wettbewerb oder individueller freiheit
basiert sondern deren strecke komplett
in staatlicher hand und somit in der
hand der einheitspartei liegen
[Musik]
schongang wird die kathedrale nicht der
browser engine oder shanghai und sie
hofft dass diese kathedrale das
wahrzeichen des neuen chinas werden
könnte in diesem sinne sehen die
entwicklungspläne vor dass die
bevölkerung dieser neuen metropole in
den nächsten jahrzehnten auf mehr als
sieben millionen einwohner wächst und
dabei gleichzeitig soll ein
vorzeigemodell der nachhaltigkeit
adressiert denn nach den vorstellungen
des chinesischen präsidenten soll schon
dann eine grüne stadt seien eine art
versuchslabor für neue urbane modelle in
einer neuen emissionsarmen industrien
verkehrsmittel und unternehmen alle
straßen sind auf die bedürfnisse
autonome fahrzeuge ausgelegt und auch
große teile der stadtverwaltung und
wirtschaft und administrativen steuerung
sondern durch künstliche intelligenz
bewältigt werden ja das alles klingt
tatsächlich lesung also wolle sich das
umweltschädliche land der welt neu
erfinden es wurden nämlich alle fabriken
und unternehmen welche die neuen
standards nicht erfüllen einfach
beschlossen seit 2017 hat die
chinesische regierung die schließung von
mehr als 5.000 unternehmen und fabriken
in der region angeordnet und der prozess
wird weitergehen bis alles gesäubert ist
darüber hinaus soll die neue metropole
auch zur entlastung des überquellenden
und verstopften peking mit seinen
horrenden mieten dauerstaus schmuck und
einfach unmenschlichen lebensbedingungen
dienen und wenn man das alles in
betracht zieht dass alles zumindest auf
den ersten blick doch gar nicht mal so
schlecht aus wird es die kpc also
schaffen hier die blaupause für den
neuen chinesischen traum zu schaffen ein
traum der wirtschaftlichen emanzipation
ohne die schädlichen nebenwirkungen der
vergangenheit ein besseres leben in
nachhaltigkeit und gerechtigkeit nun
lasst uns mal kurz innehalten denn viele
experten die das projekt wirklich
gründlich analysiert haben sie der
meinung dass es gar nicht an die
erfolgsstory ist change and treffen kann
und so die gefahr groß ist dass die
stadt komplett scheitert aber lasst mich
das erklären die idee eine stadt zu
errichten die sich fast ausschließlich
auf bürokratie beamte künstliche
intelligenz und subvention stößt die
obendrein muster für den totalen
überwachungsstaat die völlige
ausrichtung des lebens ihrer bewohner an
social scoring und partei das so sein
soll ein hort der kontrollsucht des
zentralstaats und die gleichzeitig
lichtjahre davon entfernt sein wird die
dynamik des wettbewerbs für förderung
von innovation zu nutzen oder
individuelle interessen zu
berücksichtigen ist nunmal nun was soll
ich sagen und ihr wisst genau worauf ich
hinaus will und wenn man dann noch
bedenkt den westen machtgeilen und
korrupten händen die größte ausgabe des
präventionsrates und investitions orgie
chinas liegt dann sieht es noch viel
düsterer aus die fragen wir uns an
dieser stelle stellen sollten lautet
daher kann eine neue statistik nicht an
den prinzipien des marktes orientiert
überhaupt in china mit 21 jahren das
erfolgreich sein was sie wirklich etwas
einzigartiges etwas bahnbrechendes zu
bieten was das alles für ganz china
bedeuten genau das sehen wir uns jetzt
mal an
[Musik]
geschichte eines prognostizierten
scheiterns
wenn wir aus chinesischer sicht von
einem scheitern sprechen meine damit
nicht dass die stadt nicht fertig gebaut
wird oder dass sie keinen fortschritt
für die region darstellt wir dürfen
nicht vergessen dass er sich hier um
eine unterentwickelte ländliche gegend
handelt und jede investition in
infrastruktur unternehmen krankenhäuser
universitäten und andere einrichtungen
zweifellos eine verbesserung oder
ursprünglichen situation darstellt es
sei denn man wird ersatzlos von seinem
grund und boden vertrieben aber wie
gesagt das sollte ich lieber wein
erzählen nicht wie nie ganz nüchtern und
realistisch betrachtet es ist jedoch
sehr sehr wahrscheinlich dass das modell
das camping hierfür china zu testen will
einfach nicht funktionieren wird
das erste problem ist seine
geographische lage im gegensatz zu
stellen welches an das finanzzentrum
hongkong grenzt und außerdem einen
direkten zugang zum meer hat liegt schon
an im landesinneren in einer gegend in
der es im winter sehr kalt und im sommer
sehr heiß ist in der die
lebensbedingungen grundsätzlich
unangenehm sind und obwohl sich die im
bau befindliche infrastruktur
beeindruckend ist und verspricht die
neue stadt in einer halben stunde mit
peking zu verbinden es ist nicht ganz
klar dass dies die menschen überzeugen
wird dahin zu ziehen zumindest nicht in
der großen zahl die peking erwartet
außerdem müssen wir berücksichtigen dass
es viele vorschriften und restriktionen
für private aktivitäten geben wird und
so müssen uns ansehen welche pläne für
den öffentlichen sektor bestehen der
nämlich die hauptrolle spielen soll es
kann also gut sein dass schon zu einer
super einen langweiligen beamtenstadt
wird für aus peking zwangsversetzt
apparatschiks klingt das nicht einladend
vor allem was die sozialstruktur dieser
stadt angeht denn schon iran hat auch
harte konkurrenz und zwar ähnlich china
selbst war ehrlich was würde euch dazu
veranlassen ein unternehmen im schongang
zu gründen wenn man es auch zum beispiel
im jangtse delta grund könnte na klar
ich hab ein mörderischer lockdown der
seine mitarbeiter in den wahnsinn und
tod treibt das ist ein klasse plan klar
das ist dann noch etwas unattraktiver
als mit parteibonzen und beamten nach
feierabend auf ihn zugehen aber
abgesehen von den zweifeln am erfolg
dieser stadt oder der ablehnung eines
projekts welches in der praxis nichts
anderes zu sein scheint als eine
rückkehr zu alten sowjetischen projekten
aus der mitte des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts mit denen die politische
macht der eliten der kommunistischen
partei gefestigt werden sollte ist es
nun mal so dass der ehrgeiz mitbringen
und die enorme geld zum den woll wir
sind zu einer sehr merkwürdigen art
eines museums von einer stadt führen
könnten eine ultramoderne aber eiskalte
und charakterlose stadt stil über nacht
an einem ort gebaut wurde an dem es kaum
mehr als reisfelder ärmliche
bauernhäuser darf
ich wäre nicht überrascht wenn das alles
nicht halb so erfolgreich funktioniert
wie china erwartet aber es wird
beeindruckender sein als alles was wir
im westen seit 50 jahren gesehen haben
im schlimmsten fall werden wir bis
mindestens 2035 warten müssen um zu
sehen was mich schon an passiert im
moment sind die bulldozer und kräne
bereits in den drei bezirken aktiv der
bau der haupt infrastruktur ist bereits
in vollem gange zum beispiel wurde er
schon mal mega hochgeschwindigkeit
bahnhof der mit seinen 400 75.000
quadratmetern einem kostenaufwand von
mehr als 1,1 milliarden dollar der
zentrale verkehrsknotenpunkte journal
sein sollen im dezember 2020 bereits
fertiggestellt
klar ist dass der auf jeden fall vor
einem neuen experiment stehen dass noch
ein ziel hat ein weiteres mittel zu
finden mit dem ski und seine clique ihre
persönliche macht festigen und vor allem
ihr gesicht wahren können dies haben sie
zur absoluten priorität für das ganze
land gemacht alles andere muss hinten
anstehen das wohlergehen der bürger der
gesellschaftliche und wirtschaftliche
fortschritt und sogar die
konkurrenzfähigkeit und stellung chinas
in der welt damit geht sie eigentlich in
die gleiche richtung die auch putin und
sogar kindern und eingeschlagen haben
dass ein igeln des eigenen landes
gegenüber der welt und seine verwandlung
in ein riesiges gefängnis für seine
insassen also bewohner und all das um
die inneren machtverhältnisse im staat
zu zementieren
auch die methoden sind die gleichen
zumeist die förderung niederer instinkte
in der bevölkerung wie chauvinismus
misstrauen und obrigkeitshörigkeit
gepaart mit einem kalten bürokratischen
und repressiven hightech
überwachungsstaat aber das vielleicht
größte problem an der ganzen geschichte
ist dass die parteifunktionäre denen er
seine macht zu verdanken hat fest daran
glauben dass sie gar keine andere wahl
hätten und aus einem gewissen
blickwinkel könnte man ihnen sogar recht
geben denn china war schon immer ein
land der extreme während einer
jahrtausende langen geschichte lässt es
entweder als hort der effektivität und
des aufstiegs oder als abgrund der
hoffnungslosigkeit und noch sinnloser
verschwendung vor allem der sinnlosen
verschwendung menschlichen lebens und
forschung und blütezeiten wechselten
sich so oft mit katastrophalen
hungersnöten und sozio kulturellen massa
kann ab dass einem dabei schwindlig
werden kann die chinesin war die
historische und immer zwischen ihre
verbundenheit gegenüber der familie der
dorfgemeinschaft und lokalen führung und
ihrer loyalität gegenüber dem
übermächtigen zentrale regierung ob
kaiser oder kp gespalten der
unglaubliche ökonomische druck der
letzten jahrzehnte hat für hunderte von
millionen chinesen die traditionelle
dorfgemeinschaft zerstört und eine
gewaltige ungleichverteilung innerhalb
der gesellschaft verursacht beide sind
extrem große stressfaktoren für eine
gesellschaft aber gleichzeitig war
dieser boom auch der hauptgrund warum
die menschen der partei die treue
hielten ist was versprechen vom
chinesischen traum doch angesichts des
demographischen abgrunds vor dem china
steht wird es immer mehr chinesen klar
dass dieser traum für sie nicht mehr
aufgehen wird die bisherige
legitimationsgrundlage des
machtanspruchs der kpc schwindet also im
eiltempo und leider hat man es
jahrzehnte lang sträflich versäumt das
politische system china so anzupassen so
zu reformieren dass es funktionierende
politische mechanismen gibt es wohl für
die herstellung ökologischer
gerechtigkeit als auch für den
friedlichen übergang von macht von einer
ausgelaugten bei fast allem versagen der
regierung von der alle wissen dass ihr
gesicht bereits verloren hat das aber
noch nicht zugeben dürfen den zu einer
frischen ohne belasteten führungseliten
die dem land neuen schwung verleihen
könnte die regierung sie hat einfach
schon zu viele wirklich brutale papiere
hingelegt von der ungelösten
immobilienkrise über die unterstützung
des globalen users nummer eins und
kriegsverbrechen bis zum total versagen
bei der bekämpfung des corona virus
china wagt auch hier dieser weltweit als
absolutes negativbeispiel heraus und das
muss bei den vielen corona chaos
regierungen dieser welt schon was heißen
natürlich geht es bei den derzeitigen
hunger lockdown es nicht um gesundheit
sondern um reine machtpolitik um
gesichtswahrung und das brechen des
wilden synanon konformen widerspenstigen
an bunten orten wie shanghai denn zur
gleichen zeit soll in den neuen
gleichgeschalteten metropolen der
monokultur wie schon an der neue
chinesische mensch geschaffen werden der
parteitreue bescheidene und fleißig des
systems vw sharan soll somit die stadt
gewordenes abkopplung des chinesischen
gegenentwurf zum individualistisch
freiheitlich pluralistischen system des
westens werden wird sie zum erfolg
könnten sich schnell nachahmer ständen
nicht nur in china geht das experiment
jedoch schief könnte ich hier wieder so
enden wie so oft in seiner geschichte
auf den unglaublichen boom folgt der
steile absturz meist in form von
revolutionen und begleitet von blutigen
kriegen im inneren die nach außen aber
dies ist schon wieder ein thema für ein
anderes video denn jetzt seid ihr
erstmal andere welches system wird sich
wohl durchsetzen glaubt ihr dass china
mit diesem neuen modell an seiner
globalen wirtschaftlichen erfolge aus
der vergangenheit anknüpfen kann kann
die erste große stadt des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
privatwirtschaft den rücken kehrt zu
einem vorbild für ganz china die ganze
welt werden und was könnte mit china
passieren wenn skis monströse
sozialexperiment das scheitern die immer
sind eure beiträge und diskussionen zu
diesem thema schon sehr gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses video gefallen
hat was jahr gibt es mit einem
leidvollen ist nicht das abo mit
glöckchen keines unserer videos mehr zu
verpassen natürlich freuen wir uns auch
jederzeit über eine spende von euch mit
dem bus hält dieses projekt
weiterzuführen in paper link dazu findet
jeder beschreibung unter dem video
macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]